DOES THAT SOUND EERILY SIMILAR
TO SOMETHING LIKE THE
REPARATIONS PUSH HERE?
JOINING ME NOW IS SOUTH AFRICAN
NATIVE LARA LOGAN, HOST OF
FOX NATION'S "LARA LOGAN HAS NO
AGENDA."
LARA COME A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE
NOT AWARE WHAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IN SOUTH AFRICA.
I HAVE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH TO
TRAVEL THERE MANY TIMES, AND
I'VE SEEN THIS KIND OF
DETERIORATION OVER THE LAST,
REALLY, 10-12 YEARS, MAYBE
LONGER, 15 YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN
GOING THERE.
WHAT DO WE NEED TO KNOW ABOUT
THIS?
>> WELL, MANY SOUTH AFRICANS ARE
JUST SHOCKED AT THE SPEED WITH
WHICH THIS IS SPREADING, LAURA,
AND IT IS WORST IN TWO
PROVINCES, ONE IS THE HOME
PROVINCE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT JACOB ZUMA, AND I HAVE
BEEN SPEAKING TO PEOPLE THEY
ARE, FOOD IS RUNNING LOW, THIS
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR FIVE DAYS,
AND THE STORES ARE BURNING DOWN,
THERE IS NO MILK, NO BREAD, AND
PEOPLE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
ANY FUEL FOR THEIR CARS, SO THIS
IS A PARTICULARLY DISTRESSING
SITUATION FOR MANY, MANY PEOPLE,
SO MANY KILLED AT THIS POINT,
PEOPLE ARE ASKING, WHERE IS THE
POLICE, WHERE IS THE ARMY?
AND WHILE THEY ARE GOING TO
DEPLOY MORE SOLDIERS, THERE ARE
VERY WORRYING REPORTS OF THIS
BECOMING A RACIAL ELEMENT BEING
INTRODUCED INTO THIS,
THERE IS A COMMUNITY JUST
OUTSIDE OF WHERE JACOB ZUMA IS
FROM, AND THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF REPORTS THAT ARE
FANNING THE FLAMES OF RACIAL
TENSION AND VIOLENCE THERE.
AND WHAT YOU START TO SEE IS
SOME OF THE ECHOES OF CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND THE WOKE AGENDA
THAT HAVE PROLIFERATED ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
WE ARE PAYING THE PRICE NOW FOR
BIG TECH AND FACEBOOK AND ALL
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE ABLE TO
REALLY SET THE AGENDA IN ANY
COUNTRY THAT THEY WANT, AND
WHERE PEOPLE CAN SPREAD THIS
MESSAGE AND SPREAD THIS DIVISIVE
POLITICS.
AND SOUTH AFRICA IS NO
EXCEPTION.
>> Laura: SO, THERE IS A
MARXIST ELEMENT AT PLAY HERE, IN
OTHER WORDS.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, OBAMA'S
AMBASSADOR TO SOUTH AFRICA, WHEN
OBAMA'S TERM ENDED AND HE CAME
HOME, HE BECAME THE PRESIDENT OF
THE OPEN SOCIETY FOUNDATION,
GEORGE SOROS' FOUNDATION --
YEAH.
I KNOW.
BUT WHEN HE WAS IN SOUTH AFRICA,
HE WAS VERY VOCAL ABOUT
REPARATIONS.
HE WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO WAS
PUSHING AND ENCOURAGING PUBLICLY
FOR THE SOUTH AFRICAN GOVERNMENT
TO TAKE LAND AWAY FROM WHITE
PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY WHITE
FARMERS.
30,000 WHITE FARMERS IN
SOUTH AFRICA FEED THOSE PEOPLE
AND THEY FEED OTHER PEOPLE
ACROSS SOUTHERN AFRICA, SO WHEN
YOU TAKE THAT LAND AWAY AND IT
IS NOT USED TO FARM ANYMORE, YOU
START YOUR PEOPLE.
PEOPLE SAW THAT IN NEIGHBORING
ZIMBABWE, SO THERE IS A RADICAL
ELEMENT AT PLAY HERE AND NOBODY
CAN TELL, AT THIS POINT, IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY HOW MUCH THIS
IS INVOLVED, BUT SOUTH AFRICAN
MEDIA HAS VERY QUICKLY TURNED TO
LOOKING AT WHO IS DRIVING THIS,
AND WHETHER THERE IS -- THERE
ARE OTHER FORCES, AND YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE EERILY SIMILAR ECHOES
HERE.
THERE IS A WHOLE IDEOLOGY THAT
GOES ALONG WITH OPEN SOCIETY IN
ALL OF THESE GROUPS ABOUT
JOINING A MOMENT INTO A MASS
MOVEMENT OR REVOLUTION AND
TH